hi counselor Lizarraga Denali mayor of
the London borough of Camden and
returning officer for the election held
today Thursday the 7th of May 2015 in
the Hampstead and Kilburn constituency
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes cast for each candidate at the
election is as follows
Ronnie the use of irony car roll
independent disease 113 Robin traffic
Alison you party 77 Rebecca Johnson
Green Party 2387
Simon Marcus the Conservative Party
candidate 2220 2839
Maajid Nawaz Liberal Democrats 3039
Magnus Nilsson UK Independence Party
you keep 1532 tulips edik Labour Party
23900
the number of ballot papers rejected
we're voting for more than one candidate
57 writing or mark by which voter can be
identified one unmarked one void for
uncertainty 125 total rejected votes 184
and higher be declared the Thule Sadiq
has been duly elected
I'm absolutely honored to be standing
here as the Labour MP for hamster than
Kilburn I want to start by thanking
everyone who participated in this
election whether you put your faith in
me and voted for me whether you stood in
the rain and leaflet sit for hours on
end
whether you spent every weekend knocking
on doors for me this is the reason why I
won so thank you this is the
constituency in which I've grown up
where I went to school where my parents
got married in the 1970s where I used to
write for my local paper Hampstead and
Kilburn is my home which is why I'm
proud to represent Hansen Kilburn in
Parliament and by voting for me you've
shown that you've put faith in labour
values values of fairness of social
justice of equality values about
protecting our public services about
making sure that we keep the NHS and
making sure that we look after those who
are vulnerable an economy that works for
everyone
not just for a few but now to return to
thank a few people there were volunteers
from across the world across the country
from countries like Finland America
Bangladesh everyone came across the
hulk's it's very hard it's hard to name
everyone but I will name a few people
firstly I'll say thanks to the returning
officer to all the work you've done and
all the staff who've stayed up all night
counting the votes well done
can I say thank you to Mike Cook to
Lazaro to Rachel and all the staff from
Camden Council for doing such a good job
as you always do
can I also say thank you to my fellow
candidates they've done a really good
job it's been a hard campaign so well
done to all of you I want to say thank
you to my agent Dan and to say thank you
to the chair of the CLP Jeff I want to
say thank you to Philip and Susan Healey
for their generosity and I want to say
thank you to Catherine Bly for her
never-ending support can I say thank you
to all our counselors across Camden and
Brent you really put in the hours and a
special mention to James Denslow thank
you can I say thank you to our local
businesses especially to Ruchi and to
the good ship for so much support and
finally we've got to thank our local
media whether it's the camden new
journal the hammond hi the Brenton
Kilburn times and the bengali media and
unroll mama thank you
like I said too many people to mention
but the core team Barbara James and Tom
you were amazing to my family ma paya
rupee Pepe emoji
thank you very much you put up with a
lot and come on family come on come on
come on come on mum Rafi mayor can I
finally two more thank you sigh promise
can I say thank you to my husband Chris
gentlemen take notes not only that this
man take five months off work he's
really supported me so this is my
husband did an amazing job and last but
not least my campaign manager who's
given up two years of his life come on
Oliver Denton
this man there you go so thank you
everyone if you know me you know that
the hard work has just started so
tomorrow morning team 9:00 a.m. Kilburn
highroad the campaigning starts again I
expect to see you there thank you thank
you everyone